so every Disney cember I always find a
theme to tie all the videos together but
the downside of that is whenever I do
that a lot of other movies are released
and I'm not able to give them the Disney
zember treatment I mean don't get me
wrong Disney has had its hand in a lot
of things TV shows and movies and
animation of course but as they continue
to expand and keep buying properties it
seems like there's just so much Disney
coming out all at once so this year I'm
gonna make up for that
this year it's by popular demand that's
right there's no connecting themes
there's no one studio or one style of
film we're looking at all it has to do
is have Disney's name on there somewhere
and be requested by a lot of people you
name it there'll be animated films I
haven't done yet Pixar films I haven't
done yet Disney Channel movies Marvel
films old and new even films that just
came out this year now like before some
of these I've discussed before with my
brother Rob on sibling rivalry so if you
want a longer review of some of these
movies and a different point of view you
can go and watch those but I also like
the idea of letting time pass whether it
be a lot or little and seeing if they
still have the same impact as when I
just saw them after all the sibling
rivalries are done right after we've
seen it so this allows me some time to
collect my thoughts even more it is so
cool just to see how much bigger Disney
is becoming I mean just when you thought
they couldn't get any bigger
here they are owning all these different
properties and studios and for the most
part they're turning out pretty damn
good material but again we're here to
discuss what works and what doesn't
what's timeless and what's immediately
dated and on top of that what works as
being timeless or dated and what doesn't
work as being timeless or dated so if
there's ever a Disney movie Marvel movie
Disney Channel original movie Pixar film
or whatever I haven't gotten to this is
your chance to see if I finally catch up
with it sit back and enjoy this is
Disney cember by popular demand
there is absolutely no particular order
in this at all so I'm just gonna start
with pirates of the caribbean dead men
tell no tales the fifth installment in
what seems like a never-ending series
and I don't really mean that in the best
way
this film was not a huge financial
success when it came out and you can
kind of see why I like the first Pirates
of the Caribbean movie like a lot of
people and I still make the other ones
okay but after a while you just kind of
get sick of seeing them especially when
nothing that new is being added Jack
Sparrow is back of course played again
by Johnny Depp and he's teamed up with
the son of Orlando Bloom's character
from the previous movies oh Christ can't
we just escape these characters okay in
all fairness Orlando Bloom is not in
this movie much and Keira Knightley even
less but they're replaced with two bland
good-looking cutouts that they might as
well just be orlando bloom and keira
knightley his son is the good-looking
dashing heartthrob who's in over his
head and his girlfriend is often told
she has to be one thing but of course
she doesn't want to be like I said it's
practically the same characters from the
other films blooms son wants to find a
way to break his father's curse so he
can be reunited with him and a scientist
named Karina who's confused for a which
way too many times to be funny is trying
to honor her father by finding the
Trident of Poseidon wind you know it if
the Trident is destroyed all the curses
of the sea are lifted and yeah you can
guess why everybody wants to get it but
a ghostly villain played by Javier
Bardem of course is after Jack Sparrow
because he screwed him over in the past
just like all the villains of Jack
Sparrow and he also wants to find the
Trident to possess its power
are you interested even a little if the
answer's no then this movie really
doesn't do much to get you invested I
can't say this is an awful flick I mean
it's not like there's moments where I'm
saying shut up or this is so annoying or
anything like that it's just kind of
bland which is funny because if this
movie came out 20 years ago it probably
wouldn't be these effects would be seen
as impressive these designs creative
these characters and their relationships
odd but fun but because we have seen
this so many times it's just feeling
formulaic Johnny Depp's just running
around acting like Jack Sparrow and he
does it fine but why are we still
interested in this we've seen him do it
in the other movies and
anything interesting that could be done
with him has kind of already been done
there's only one moment that actually
gave me new insight into his character
and hardly has any words in it he has
this compass that he knows if he gives
it away it'll bring back Javier Bardem
allowing him to potentially hunt him
down and kill him he trades it of course
for a bottle of rum but he looks down at
it and kind of smiles and says father
it's not almost like he wants to be
chased he wants to be hunted down that's
just kind of the life he chose that was
kind of interesting but aside from that
one little moment everyone just kind of
stays in their usual roles and they're
not really as entertaining as they used
to be sparrows antics are getting tired
the young man and young woman are there
to offset his goofiness even Jeffrey Raj
who's usually my favorite part of these
movies doesn't seem to bring the same
energy or comedy to it there's I guess a
twist about his connection to one of the
characters and honestly it doesn't feel
earned when you think about it there's a
lot going on with this connection but it
just kind of feels thrown in at the last
minute they all of a sudden build up
like the whole film was focusing on it
even though it clearly wasn't and again
that's a big problem with this film
focus so many of the pirate films have
that problem even the first one there's
a ton of stuff going on but you kind of
get it it's these pirates that want to
lift this curse that's it all the other
movies just throw too much at you and
sometimes that can be fun in the film
juggling all these different characters
and plot devices and such but when
you're constantly asking yourself what
every character's motivation was and
what's the next thing they have to do or
the magic word they have to say or the
secret device they have to find it feels
more like homework than a riveting
adventure even Javier Bardem who's
usually so good and so entertaining I'm
not sure what he's doing here I was
hoping for something really crazy and
over-the-top but he's just covered in
fake CG and a lot of echo and distortion
added to his voice I'm wondering why
they even picked him even Davy Jones for
his goofy as he was had more of a
personality than this guy it just
doesn't feel like his identity is
fleshed out if they made him super
serious and super still while the CG on
it moves around that could be
interesting or that made him super goofy
and big-eyed and having fun that could
be kind of interesting too but instead I
guess
it's supposed to be halfway between the
two and it's just kind of a mess the
effects range from really good to really
pathetic
seems like an island they're supposed to
reflect the stars in the sky or even
surprisingly a young Johnny Depp are
done pretty well but then they do stuff
like slow down these zombie sharks you
can really get a good look at how
amazing this scene is and just look at
it you know nothing's there why is that
impressive
and again the ghost pirates just look
like all the other ghost pirates that
ever been fought in these films they're
just not that threatening anymore the
only scene that really worked like
everything in it clicked perfectly is
when Jax Barrow and the scientists are
about to get executed the comedy the
action the stunts the escape the lines
it's all super funny well choreographed
and very impressive aside from that it's
just kind of everything you've already
seen in the pirates films which don't
get me wrong there's some people that
might really enjoy that when the second
Sin City movie came out I loved it
even though a lot of people said they
didn't enjoy it cuz it just felt like
the same thing that was in the last one
well I love that world and the
characters and the environments so much
I didn't mind something similar I can
see some fancying the same thing about
this maybe they do just kind of want
that Pirates of the Caribbean experience
and these characters to come back and
just run around and look goofy and fight
ghosts and so forth if that's what
you're looking for this will definitely
give you a your fix but if you're
looking for that same feeling of comedy
excitement fun and thrills that the
first one gave then you're in for some
really bad eggs
[Music]
you